Tate's jail time just got extended for a
third time but Romanian authorities
apparently still have no clear evidence
there are still no charges against him
yet Andrew Tate and his brother will
stay in jail until the end of March at
least but there's also something strange
happening the two women who were locked
up with the Tate Brothers his two female
accomplices who allegedly helped take
traffic all these women are no longer in
jail they are now kept under house
arrest hmm quite suspicious why are the
Tate Brothers rotting in a tiny jail
cell while the two women get to go home
the reason for that could be a betrayal
in his closest Circle have they started
snitching on Tate and this is their
reward if they snitched on him the three
months in jail may only be the beginning
of Andrew Tate's darkest nightmare click
the link in the pinned comment to learn
how the world really works